the biggest news in the fantasy football
league is that
michael rappaport has been named the new
commissioner of the league now the way
this came about is jason kaplan has been
the commissioner and at the end of last
season jason made it clear he had no
desire to continue
being the commissioner
yes so then what happened was there was
a vote everyone voted for jd michael and
jd responded with i would rather quit
this league than be the commissioner and
i just wanna and i just wanna stop you
right there that that kind of attitude i
would rather quit this league
is why the league is [ __ ] cause you got
jd this guy i don't even think this
guy's 40 he acts like he's like a 73
year old man
with
like like like a bad foot and like you
know real health problems what a whiny
[ __ ] he said i'd rather quit the league
than be the commissioner i also said i
wanted to raise the stakes i'm not
saying i want to make a like a thousand
dollars instead of making it 200
uh uh a a buy-in why don't we make let's
up it to i was trying to be i knew no
one would be go for it but i said let's
do 350.
that cheap [ __ ] richard christie i'm not
doing it i'd rather quit the league and
i was like all right this is going
nowhere jd i think would have upped the
money it was richard christie who said
i don't want to up the money so then i
didn't take it any further oh jd you
want to be what do you got to say sorry
i had to get my 70 year old ass uh 73 73
year old sitting here and yes i have no
problem with the league dying i don't
care you don't love fantasy football
anymore
sure i do but it does cause a lot of
stress so why do you join the league
every year if it's so stressful for you
jd it's supposed to be fun i ask myself
that every year
but everything everything you enjoy
causes you stress yes that is very true
so it gives you an amount of enjoyment
uh there's some enjoy yeah hold on when
you do well yes you i i enjoy it but
when you don't do well it is the worst
and then i feel like i wasted two
hundred dollars i'm excited about this
league this year because
one thing i love about what about what
about it there's nothing there's nothing
to be excited about this league
michael shut up for a second all right
in the past there has been uh they tried
to do a coup there's been a coup attempt
to kick you out an attempted coup to
kick you out of the league people were
not happy with the trash talking we're
not happy with your behavior we're not
happy with your antics and how you were
drafting they said you were cheating
using your son to assist you you had an
assistant gm
now you are running the league michael
you are the voice of the league who
would you kick out of the league now
that you have the power bowie
kick him right the [ __ ] out
kick him kick him right the [ __ ] out i
mean right the [ __ ] and i let the rest
of the people in the league see what
happened with me when they tried to run
the coup on me
is the fans and inevitably my guy super
john hein
we took a vote the fans were like
absolutely not don't kick him out and
then the league voted and john hein had
the what is it called the the what vote
the swing vote
and super john hein came through for me
and uh that's why i'll always be loyal
to him because of that and just he's a
solid [ __ ] guy
but i know that coup was attempted by
that rotten tooth
dusty
gorilla do you think gary was the
driving i don't know
i don't think
i know for a fact and it blew up in his
big [ __ ] face right in front of his
big [ __ ] teeth
you